I've met you for the first time yes but
come through the door use with your
partner you told him you don't need to
follow you upstairs yes you have a
partner kiss you up and you came inside
right you said you're gonna go up to the
21st floor yeah I told you that's got a
lot of steps we couldn't it's got a
sweat card you can't come in I said come
in and if you said she's got a phobia we
counted up the lift I told her to look
on our floors look at her toes to
breathe with me I told her not to look
at anything and we did this we got to
the 21st floor then she gave me a hug
now I just met her now
a second ago you said that men won't do
something are you talking about common
DC it's not common decency